Norfolk mental health advocate Charlotte
Underwood who self-harmed from the ages
of 14 to 20 Charlotte very good morning
to you and thanks coming out to talk
about this I think you're 22 now and why
did you begin self-harm and what form
did it take I didn't start self harming
on purpose it was something that just
develops after feeling quite anxious and
alone I was quite heavy in my cutting
but it was because I had no healthy
outlet and I just didn't know where else
to turn what do you say to those people
who heard what you just said and say
well anxiety and loneliness have been
part and parcel of being a teenager for
as long as there have been teenagers but
people didn't used to resort to to
cutting as you say I think it's more to
do with the way the world has changed
and the lack of communication between
all of us really and at the same time
there is more to self harm than just
cutting so whether it didn't exist
before it's definitely questionable when
you when you say we don't talk to each
other anymore I think I paraphrase what
you said there is that is that a
function of social media that we lots of
young people now exist in her in a
bubble that's created by their online
life definitely something I always say
is that in a world of mass communication
we've learned how to properly
communicate and I think that applies
quite well to that was there anything
specifically which which prompted you to
do it was the one event was it an
accumulation of things it was sorry it
was an accumulation of feeling very
unwell for a long time but not
understanding what was going on in
myself so I had a mental illness but I
didn't know I had it and that was
terrifying
what did it take for you to break the
cycle did it require outside help or is
it just something you were able to work
through yourself it's something that
took eight years of perseverance and
accepting the ups and downs and learning
to talk about it
and get those feelings out of my head
and finding healthy outlets rather than
the not-so-good ones like so far yeah
really this morning a bit more about
this
words like romanticizing glamourizing
self-harm which seemed completely
paradoxical how could it how is it even
possible to glamorize self harming is it
I don't think it is I think it's again
it's that stigma where people are maybe
trying to avoid talking about it and
spin it into something even worse than
it is if you are somebody perhaps on the
brink of going back to school maybe
thinking hard about exams that are
looming and you think that perhaps this
is a an avenue you may consider going
down if you're a young person a teenager
a particular girl because this is
something which we're told affects girls
far more than boys what's your message
to somebody who's who's contemplating
doing something like this you never know
what someone's gonna say to you if you
tell them that you need help you don't
have to suffer alone people will listen
and you can learn to not self harm or
prevent it and I guess stop those
thoughts just by having a healthy outlet
and having someone to talk to Charlotte
you've talked to us this morning we
appreciate it thanks very much indeed